- I'm gay but I'm not a fashionista.
- I'm gay but I don't really
prefer hook up culture.
- I'm gay but you wouldn't
exactly call me promiscuous.
- I'm still not good at talking to guys.
- I'm gay but I'm not interested
in your other friend
simply because he's also gay.
- But I know nothing about
Madonna or Lady Gaga.
- Not into Britney Spears.
- I'm gay but I still don't
know how to dress myself.
- I'm not into designer labels.
- But I don't like to brunch.
- I'm gay but I don't want
to be your gay best friend.
- But I don't want to give you a makeover.
- But I'm not a gym rat.
- But I don't like the
stereotypical cut body.
- I'm gay but I still go to church
and I'm religious.
- But I've never seen an
episode of Will and Grace.
- Never seen an episode
of RuPaul's Drag Race.
- But I don't think I've ever
seriously Z-snapped at anybody.
- But I don't like drinking very much.
I've actually never been drunk.
- I'm gay but my main
identity isn't just being gay.
- I'm gay and I love
studying different language.
- And I'm in a choir.
- And I like to write poetry.
- And I do love a good brunch.
- And I do consider myself fashionable.
- I'm gay and I love
using the word fabulous.
- And sometimes I do say, "Hey, girl!"
- And I have four tattoos.
- 15 tattoos.
- And body piercings.
- I'm gay and I like to shoot guns.
- And I'm really into archery.
- And I love to hike.
- And I like to do parkour.
- And I play badminton three times a week.
- And I came out at the age of 18.
- I am gay and most of my friends aren't.
- And I'm colorblind.
- And I have experienced
bullying in my life.
- And I have bipolar disorder.
- And I'm also sensitive.
- And I curse like a sailor.
- And I graduated valedictorian
of my high school.
- I'm gay and I'm a filmmaker.
- And I'm an illustrator.
- And I'm a writer.
- And I'm an actor.
- And I'm a chef.
- And I own a dog care business.
- And I'm a fitness trainer.
- And I'm becoming a therapist.
- I'm gay and I love, love, love cats.
- And I love dogs.
- And I like pop music.
- Huge fan of Beyonce.
- Britney Spears.
- Lady Gaga and Mariah
Carey and Whitney Houston
and Dolly Parton and Christina Aguilera
and yeah, I love Barbara Streisand.
- And I'm a huge comic book nerd.
- And I love playing Pokemon.
- I'm gay and I'm obsessed
with RuPaul's Drag Race.
- I'm gay and I like the Kardashians.
- Love Will and Grace.
- And one of my favorite past times
is falling into a YouTube black hole.
- I'm gay and I'm from Great Britain.
- I'm gay and I'm a proud, black man.
- And I'm half Mexican
and Native American.
- And I'm Chinese and Vietnamese.
- And I'm from the UK.
- And I'm transgender.
- And also Two-Spirit.
- And I like to show off
my non-binary male body.
- I'm gay and I've only
been in one relationship.
- And I believe in monogamy.
- And I'm poly.
- And I love body hair.
- And I'm into the leather community.
- And I want to get married one day.
- And I'm also really excited
to be a father one day.
And I also have a great
relationship with my dad.
- I'm gay and I'm an uncle.
- And I'm a brother.
- And I'm a son.
- I'm gay and I'm an activist.
- And I think everyone
should have equal rights.
- And I'm a huge feminist.
- I'm gay and I advocate for safe sex.
And because I'm on PrEP
I'm not afraid to have sex with someone
based on their HIV status.
- I'm gay and I try to educate myself
about the other letters in LGBT.
- And I want to see better
queer characters on TV
and now just ones that look like me.
- And I know that our community
still has a lot of work to do
but we're still beautiful.
- I'm gay and I'm not
afraid to let people know.
- I'm gay and I love it.
- And I would not have it any other way.
- I'm gay and I'm really glad I'm gay.
(simple, upbeat music)
- I'm gay and I'm not only gay.
- I'm gay and that's just one part of me.